yeah welcome to this video yeah playing
the Tasmanian devil here okay like 14 c4
to get something different getting the
reversed grown pre-attack hmm yeah I
like III year but they have D Phi of
here and he's playing it yeah i think
the sister relatively best continuation
black it's getting the pawn back bit of
a weird thing to diplay defy the night
before but it turns out to be really
okay for black I've played this a bit as
black at least them once in a while okay
very quick Bishop to b6 maybe I can
challenge this night down ok might go
back I might just go back to f6 could be
and that could be right oh he's going
down that's a bit surprising why would
you go to before in this position
hmm okay how do I go about this I have a
three and before just not bad maybe do
this I mean not sure if its best but
it's not a bad way to play one thing is
that i have beehive now which basically
forces them to capture so let's do that
otherwise I'll take c6 and win a pawn
okay you can go back to be eight but
that looks really strange so let's do
this and I get the queenside opened up
really quickly and I don't know yeah
exactly i mean i don't know if he wants
to allow this to be taken but ok now i
can go I think I can do this right
Bishop to a three that looks like it's
the right placement well quickly played
isn't this just a very problematic pin I
thought this wasn't one I'm sorry hope I
thought this wasn't even possible okay
so he's giving up the exchange them um
okay I can also play queen bee three
check that is also looking quite
promising look f7 this Bishop d5 that
loses straight away so I can't insert
this check the best resign I know he
resigns me yeah but what he hears he has
no move here right if he goes here I go
Bishop b5 and this Nets big material and
king of here I'm taking this and he
cannot even capture here because the
night hangs yeah that was a really quick
break down here of blacks position and
surprisingly yeah I think the problems
start here I think here he should just
play Knight f6 yeah maybe he can also
just take I mean that's probably not a
terrible move as well either I i I've
improved on that mistake a little bit
but it still happens yeah that's it
certainly playable as well
but I expected 90 f6 that sets rather
than normal putting the night back to
the place there where it belongs yeah
now I was thinking maybe queen bee three
comes into consideration yes Queen e7
though for Bishop e6e form is actually
how it is normally played this kind of
position black once and white once the
spawn in the center and possibly can go
deform and short order that's a normal
position but this loses lots of time
really not sure about this well d 4 was
also interesting yeah i briefly
considered that but that's not a bad
setup either just putting the pawn that
one before preparing queen bee three
there's b5 yeah however I think he
should maybe play Knight c7 now to look
at those critical squares there on b5
and d5 now I can still play this move
but it's not as effective yeah something
something like that for example looks
quite good it's a matter of development
yeah it's some it is a see form slowish
type of opening but i have the much
better development here and his center
is a bit shaky considering the king
position here the move f5 isn't helping
black at all you would really like to
have the porn back on f7 yeah but here
this is tricky now yeah that's quite
yeah the computer already gives an ID c7
giving up a pond and after this and
white is clearly better yeah the night
on a six is not well placed and I'm just
threatening to take on d6 which which
which really is a problem and this loses
straight away and he played this like in
two seconds and 97 is the computer
computer suggestion with a clear edge
for white but not a win yet something
like that okay it's clear that white is
much better he has this weird package
your firm of pieces and whitis has
everything like active very nice
position but it's not a sum not winning
big material quickly
the way it went I was just winning the
house okay well thanks for watching